how old were you when you decided you
wanted to direct television that's a
very good question i think i was 41
when i decided to to direct television
so it was
crazy and honestly i didn't think i was
going to direct television i thought
some new um
movies
honestly
so
that was the goal at least
and my very first project ended up being
a movie of the week a christmas movie
and then from there that got me into
television so
because there's so many new tv shows
coming up all the time
um
for any director to say you know i'll
never do tv is silly because there's
just so much
work right now so yeah so now i'll do
both and fantastic work i mean
television is a lot of series and
adaptations and things that yeah maybe
wasn't the same in the 90s yes you know
when we think of
gen xers think of television yeah
i think also the fact not only is is
television amazing now
but
folks are not going to the movie
theaters i mean
10 million dollars is what spielberg got
for uh
for west side story which is less than
into the heights
so it's like and this is spielberg
so
folks are not going to the theaters
anymore unless it's going to be like
this really big
you know marvel situation so
spider-man's going to kill
spider-man's going to kill but
you know they spent 100 million dollars
to make west side story it made 10
million this first weekend it's going to
lose a lot of money
so
right now the way to do it is not
necessarily unless you're going to be on
a marvel project you definitely want to
you know obviously you know take
whatever job you can take but tv is
where it's at because
you know you get multiple you get more
than one
more than one um
episode uh there's a there's so much
content right now
and if i just joined the director's
guild
and
you know the director's skill the
minimum for directed skill
is a lot of money and you get residuals
so it's like
you know that's to me that's the way to
go
great congratulations thank you
you said you just joined the director's
guild yeah i just joined the director's
guild and you know it's a dream of mine
in fact i had a um
it's funny i think this was
2019 i had
put a
post on my instagram page and in it i
said by the end of the year i wanted to
join the writers guild
the producers guild and the director
skill by the end of 2019.
2020 comes shuts all that down so i'm
like okay well you know we'll see what
happens there and then i was fortunate
enough earlier this year
to um to work on a director skilled uh
project for a tv series
called games people play on b-e-t so the
way it works is for you to join the
union
you have to direct a union job
and
um if you have not joined the union
which was in my case
you uh once you do the job you have to
join and either you can go ahead and put
down the
thirteen thousand dollars that it costs
to join or you can just do payment plans
so that's what i decided to do so i said
you know here's a little bit of money
now and then i make small payments uh
throughout the rest of the year um
so it's it's it's a big investment you
don't have to join well then put it this
way
yeah you don't have to join but
you won't be able to join you won't be
able to direct another director's guild
job unless you join so kind of like sag
it's a similar kind of situation there
um
but yeah so you simply have to you know
have to direct a dga job
so you found a job that was union and
you kind of that that's how you get sort
of grandfathered in is you and then you
say i'm willing to pay these dues
correct so yeah so what happened is that
as far as what happened with my in my
case is the company that i that i um do
a non-union show for um called states
and sinners
the one of the executive producers there
knows somebody from bet and because of
kovit bet
they have a show called gains people
play
and they have 10 episodes i believe each
season
they decided because okova to only use
one director to do all 10 episodes
however they said you know what we want
to give this guy a break
so let's bring one director to come in
to do one episode so the people from bet
got in contact with this executive of
this other company that i've worked with
over the past three four seasons on this
tv series and they say hey do you know
anybody who could come in and direct
this and they they threw my name in the
hat so i had to actually interview with
um with the uh executive producer of
that sir of that show
and uh turns out that um it was tracy
edmonds
who um
she
we we know some of the same people she
used to she's owned a record label
and one of the people that was her star
at her record label i went to high
school with at the performing arts high
school
and so we talked about the fact that we
know john b we got along very well so
she hired me for the job and so
because she hired me for the job that's
how i got into the dga
and then you get the
announcement that you need to pay
the 13 000 by a certain date yeah so
after you join the dga well while you're
in the process of working like you're
doing all your prep and pre-production
you get a you get a phone call and they
say hey look one of the producers for
the show says hey look you know you're
not dga you're gonna have to join
to do this so just know that you know
that that's coming
i finish the show i get a letter and
they're like okay hey look
you know congratulations on your job but
you're gonna need to join
um
um so
you know like i said i could have just
said no
kept the money
and then just work on another non-union
job
but now that i've
joined you know and i'm making the
payments and everything i'm not supposed
to work anymore not union jobs so that's
gonna like take me out of that running
for non-union jobs and right now most of
the jobs i've been doing have been
non-union so whenever something pops up
um i get in contact with the director's
guild so i had one job
that i was already booked
before i had done the dga job i was
already booked to do
um and i said hey look guys
i already had this gig before the dj job
is it okay they said well can you send
me the proof of that
give me the proof of that so i went
ahead and showed them the emails and
they're like okay not a problem so i was
able to finish that
non-union job
and now i'm completely you know union
interesting so similar to actors then
same thing that they can't
yes yeah problems of prosperity so now
you're going to this new level yeah and
you kind of can't go back yeah yeah and
it's almost like you know like like
writing in first class do you really
want to go back to coach you really know
because again the money you know when i
look at what i was making on a per
episode basis it's it's probably two and
a half times more
on a dga job than when i was making on a
non-union basis you know so it's like do
you really want to go back not really
in a different um
different set in terms of
you know not not not
talent talent can be non-union as well
but i mean you're going to be going into
sort of these higher realms
interesting yeah yeah more money will be
sent per episode sure you know a million
dollars 2 million bucks 3 million bucks
and
you know you see that with
crafty you see that with with lunch you
see that with you know accommodations
for where you where you'll be staying
your your your trailer you see that in
the clothing you you know oh the number
of extras or background that you could
bring on um the cars that you that drive
on onto the uh you know into the scene
so
it's the same thing
you know it's it's it's it's the same in
the sense that it's the same widget you
know meaning that
you turn on the camera you get some
actors
up camera lights that's the same thing
but yeah you're right it will make
things a lot easier i think and i think
the quality of the work
will uh will go to another level
by working on some of these larger
projects